so how does it make you feel
you can sense the waves
you know how strong they are my
policeman starring harry styles emma
corrin and david dawson will have its
world premiere at tiff this year the
film is set in the 1950s and follows a
policeman who marries a teacher while
also being in a relationship with a
museum curator the movie follows their
emotional journey spanning decades
another big toronto premiere the highly
anticipated queer rom-com bros written
by and starring billy eichner it's the
first gay rom-com ever made by a major
studio the entire cast everyone's lgbtq
all the actors even in the straight
roles so these big movie producers came
to me and said we want you to write a
rom-com about a gay couple
strangely enough i i think i'm the first
openly gay man to ever write and star in
their own studio film is that wild yeah
and you know those facts are exciting
they're also a little infuriating
because you're like it shouldn't have
been me there are so many other people
who deserved it and i just lucked out
what's going on
[Music]
that's cool
[Music]
and the inspection starring jeremy pope
and gabrielle union will also have its
world premiere at tiff
[Music]
maureen
no you ace gayer than two left shoes and
everybody can see it the film follows a
young gay black man rejected by his
mother joining the marines and doing
whatever it takes to succeed in a system
that cast him aside
are you now have you ever been a
homosexual no sir
i will break you